o buonasera sono acqua da questa mattina
presto li ho visti tutti ed è stato
bellissimo veramente vi ringrazio perché
è stato una ricchezza per me devo
parlare di creatività
sì sono io ho girato il mondo come gang
el mi sono divertito un sacco chiedetemi
tutti a chè fortunato si sono stato
molto fortunato ho fatto gli anni
ottanta e gli anni novanta
ho gestito tutta la migrations strategy
dal verde al rosso e mi sono divertito
un sacco
allora non me ne rendevo conto perché
andava su e giù dagli aerei e giravo
come un pazzo
però ho imparato veramente tanto ma non
ci sono arrivato per caso
sono figlio di una famiglia di operai
gente semplice figuratevi che tutto è
iniziato con una bocciatura
il professor colombini ha chiamato il
mio papà e gli ha detto signor brini
scusi che lavoro fa lei e mio papà io
faccio l'operaio si era vestito bene
pervenire al colloquio
io faccio l'operaio è secondo me
maurilio dovrebbe fare la stessa cosa
dovrebbe lavorare cioè li trovi un
lavoro perché non è veramente portato
per la pubblicità e la grafica è quello
signori è stato il mio calcio nel culo
che il calcio nel culo che è stato un
passo in avanti perché così ho deciso
che avrei lavorato suonato a lavorare in
fabbrica sulle macchine da stampa era
sempre un po vicino alla grafica la
pubblicità stampa volo e copertine dei
dischi però studiavo la sera studiavo la
sera e mi sono fatto un bel mazzo
ringraziando quel calcio nel culo sono
entrato in piccole agenzie di
comunicazione e poi ma come non è matura
no non me ne vado ma questo ve lo
ricorderete è stato uno degli spot che
mi ha praticamente premiato è fatto
diventare molto famoso ero diventato
finalmente un pubblicitario
pubblicitario nella mecca neri sono
italiana per cui ero pagato giravo il
mondo ero molto felice e molto contento
figuratevi che una volta dovevo partire
per girare il mio primo spot in
sudafrica ma essendo io figlio di operai
che arrivavo dal quartiere gratosoglio
di milano non avevo il passaporto per
cui corre giù prendi il taxi vai alla
questura fa immediatamente però rapporto
e chi ti trovo sotto la mccann il
professor colombini professore ma cosa
fai tu quadrini c'era la scritta
mccanney ma ve la vedete
l'inquadratura bellissima io tutto
elegante con la scritta mccann e il taxi
scusi prof ma devo andare devo andare
che devo prendere il taxi è stata una
delle più belle soddisfazioni della mia
vita
questo per dire alle persone che sono
giovani e che sono in sala che a volte
il calci nel culo
sono un passo in avanti è inutile stare
a guardare e pantaloni sporchi altra
lezione importante che voglio far
passare alle persone che fanno i
cosiddetti creativi che ormai sono
diventati sempre più creativi digitali
ma io sono un attivo cartaceo e lo
dicevo prima germano che vi ha premiato
tante volte c'è si lavorava col
pennarello con la carta con con la colla
che faceva piangere gli occhi e il
passaggio dal digitale al cartaceo dal
cartaceo al digitale io l'ho veramente
vissuto sulla mia pelle per cui sono
veramente contento di aver potuto vedere
questa rivoluzione però voglio passarvi
questa lezione che per me è stato
importante penso che sia una lezione che
non ha passaggi digitali
avevo appena fatto questo spot
[Musica]
stephen r
l'amore al prossimo andando a girare una
settimana in islanda perché allora
c'erano tanti soldi per cui la modella
angelina bellissima andiamo a presentare
lo spot che era molto più lungo adesso
che ho fatto solamente una sintesi è il
cliente non mi piace è triste e scuro se
buio e non piace ma signor stephan el
cioè abbiamo scelto insieme la modella
signor stephan el e abbiamo scelto
insieme di andare in islanda
in questo ambiente così cupo così scuro
dove lui arriva da dietro e la braccia
perché è l'amore addosso si cosette di
siti alla sorella e la sorella bianca me
nun me piace tanto se bruto di scuro si
è morto a qualcosa di vivo e ma poi non
capite perché io con la mia presunzione
dell'hard diretto superpagato
superpremiato così no perché voi non che
il mio capo mi chiamò e mi dice possiamo
uscire un secondo
usciamo e mi ha attaccato letteralmente
al muro cioè mi ha preso per il bavero a
mi ha attaccato al muro e mi ha detto
porta rispetto per quella persona che
sta investendo i soldi in comunicazione
chissà tu e la tua mogliettina come
romperete le scatole a chi vende i
divani per la vostra casetta del cavolo
era vero
al sabato andavamo in giro a vedere i
mobili per la nostra casa ed eravamo di
grandeur un pisco rompiscatole ad esso
rientri sorride umilmente gli dici che
farà il possibile per rimontare lo spot
e così abbiamo fatto
sono rientrato ho sorriso ho rimontato
lo spot ho cambiato le luci mettendo le
luci più chiare possibili quaggia vedete
le luci molto chiare e ho cercato le
scene più sorridenti morale cliente
approvato questa è stata la più grande
lezione che io voglio passare a tutte le
persone ci vuole umiltà umiltà
non c'è nessun mondo a due velocità che
possa cancellare questa dote la dote di
capire che siamo dei comunicatori di
capire che abbiamo la responsabilità di
portare avanti un progetto di un cliente
la parola comunicare nasce da comunis
ager mettere in comune condividere molti
creativi sono presuntuosi non pensano a
quello che stanno facendo molti creativi
non si domandano neanche a chi va un
prodotto perché perché non pensano che i
target sono la propria mamma
il proprio papà i propri fratelli e
propri amici
bisogna sempre aver presente questa cosa
essere umili e pensare di parlare alla
propria fidanzata
allora sicuramente si ha rispetto per il
prodotto che si prende in considerazione
ma ormai il mondo è decisamente cambiato
io dico fortunatamente io ho vissuto
l'epoca dove le aziende parlavano bottom
up
adesso le aziende sono costrette a
vedere che il linguaggio nasce dal basso
per cui è una grandissima fortuna ma io
penso che le regole che vi ho detto non
cambino
ci vuole sempre una grande dose di
umiltà una grande dose di rispetto per
il target e soprattutto per il prodotto
che si prende in considerazione perché
dietro un prodotto c'è una storia un
sacrificio è un'azienda recentemente a
un imprenditore italiano che fa amaro e
gatto ma scusi ma
sonoro non posso dire il nome sono
quattro generazioni che voi fate questa
amara ma state scherzando facciamo un
libro che facciamo un libro meglio
no non me la voglio tirare ma no ma è
importante è importante e portar fuori
radice di quattro generazioni
così abbiamo fatto un libro bellissimo
sul centenario ci ho impiegato un anno
un anno ma perché lui continuava a tirar
fuori materiali
bisogna avere rispetto bisogna avere
rispetto e pensare che abbiamo una
grande fortuna abbiamo il compito di
prendere una cosa di studiarla
attentamente viverla e portarla fuori
questo è il ruolo di un comunicatore io
vi lascio con uno dei miei proverbi
preferiti che ho fatto mio e vi invito
soprattutto i nativi digitali a tenere
in considerazione fermati un attimo e
arriverai prima è un proverbio orientale
invece di girarsi immediatamente
attraverso il computer a cercare
immagini shutter stufare brigare
fermatevi un attimo prendete in
considerazione quello che dovete fare
ragionate cercate di avere più
informazioni possibili e poi portatelo
fuori e poi vi lascio con il mio
proverbio preferito è mio
la pubblicità è l'anima del commercio ma
solo per un commercio che ha l'anima
grazie
[Applauso]